et pour parler de cette actualité deux
invités m'ont rejoint en plateau
Joséphine Coleman berger bonsoir bonsoir
maire de la commune de plaisir lui aussi
de nombreux incidents à déplorer durant
ce week-end et dans la nuit dernière on
va en parler avec vous en face de vous
Rudy enzinga qui est avec nous aussi
bonsoir vous êtes vous le président de
l'association Jeunesse sans frontières
associations qui travaillent avec les
jeunes de Mantes-la-Jolie qui œuvre sur
le lien social humanitaire et l'objectif
c'est la culture et l'art pour un monde
meilleur il y a également aussi avec
nous par visio-conférence Guillaume
dordet bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes vous donc secrétaire
du syndicat secrétaire régional du
syndicat Alliance police nationale dans
les Yvelines première réaction Joséphine
Coleman's berger alors peut-être déjà un
point à plaisir sur les rassemblements
qu'on a vu se dérouler un peu partout en
France à Plaisir combien de personnes
sont venues à la journée plus de 250
devant la mairie ce matin j'étais
d'ailleurs très surprise que il y ait un
retour aussi vif de la population alors
qu'on a annoncé ça hier soir mais on a
senti non seulement je dirais une envie
forte d'être là mais aussi une grande
émotion vraiment très très grande
émotion parce que tout le monde ressent
la même chose c'est-à-dire où on va quoi
c'est très très inquiétant même si on
sait que les choses se sont calmées la
nuit dernière mais aujourd'hui on est
véritablement sur une difficulté de
compréhension puisque il y a une attaque
qui est une attaque vis-à-vis des
piliers de la démocratie et de la
République donc on peut comprendre
certaines choses peut-être mais en tout
cas les réactions qui ont eu lieu ces
jours-ci nous fait nous font comprendre
que il y a une
difficulté peut-être à dialoguer avec
avec ces jeunes donc je pense que on a
encore beaucoup de travail à faire je
crois vraiment le président de
l'Association des Maires près de 150
bâtiments municipaux qui ont été
victimes d'attaque là on a les mêmes
plus loin ce weekend avec on disait la
taille du domicile du maire de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses ça vous fait quoi
justement de recevoir ce soutien de voir
que nombreuses personnes des habitants
d'autres représentants puissent venir à
ce genre de rassemblement je pense que
c'est important parce que justement les
élus aujourd'hui on est plutôt je dirais
dans un dans un regard qui est mitigé
puisque aujourd'hui on prend des
décisions qui sont des décisions qui
sont pas forcément les nôtres qu'on nous
impose parce que l'État aussi se
décharge de pas mal de choses sur les
collectivités du coup nous on est en
première ligne on donne l'impression
qu'on n'est pas forcément à l'écoute de
l'habitant puisqu'on est obligé de
prendre des décisions parfois un peu
dures et le fait d'avoir les habitants
qui viennent à nous pour nous dire qui
sont là qui savent qu'on est là pour
pour eux pour défendre la cité pour
défendre la ville j'aime pas trop ces
mots guerriers là ça ne me plaît pas je
préfère parler de tristesse et de
douleur et je n'aime pas en plus le côté
binaire il y a des gentilles il y a des
méchants c'est pas du tout comme ça
qu'on fonctionne en tout cas moi je
fonctionne pas comme ça à plaisir je
crois qu'il y a des choses à mettre en
place des vrais décisions à prendre que
l'on n'a pas pris jusqu'à présent mais
des décisions intelligentes et pas des
décisions extrêmes
on peut aussi mettre fin c'est bien ce
qu'elle regarde vous portez justement
sur ses rassemblements de soutien aux
élus on a vu les élus qui ont été visés
alors pas forcément que les élus mais
aussi les bâtiments municipaux les
mairies c'est le cas à Mantes-la-Jolie
il y a l'annexe de la mairie de
Mantes-la-Jolie au Val Fourré dans le
quartier du Val Fourré qui a été
incendie et qui a été détruite par un
incendie oui du coup
nous la premièrement on l'a vécu on l'a
mal vécu parce que c'est un social une
structure qui est là pour aider les
familles qui pour aider les habitants
mais quelque part c'est jeunesse là on a
comprend parce qu'à partir du moment où
elle est pas écouté ah bah supprimer
autrement et c'est pas au moment de la
crise justement où il faut être ou faut
être dans la réaction mais plutôt dans
l'action dans dans le quotidien et c'est
ce qu'on Martel un peu à toutes nos à
tous nos partenaires c'est vraiment de
de continuer à faire des actions de
continuer à être là pour eux les
entendre à les accompagner et comme la
mer le dit à l'instant c'est important
de continuer à travailler parce qu'il y
a beaucoup de travail encore beaucoup de
travail donc le fond de la colère vous
le comprenez la forme on a quand même
moins du mal à la comprendre cette forme
de colère
dès qu'on regarde de l'histoire de
France on peut voir que quand même le
peuple français qui est un peuple de
révolutionnaire quelque part je dis pas
que je suis pas en train de de
cautionner ce qui a été fait mais on
regarde que là on pourra on va écouter
les jeunes parce que le geste a été fort
et je ne dis pas que qu'ils doivent
continuer c'est pas du tout ce que je
dis mais on a l'impression que le
dialogue n'a jamais été voulu n'a jamais
on n'a jamais tenté de nouer le dialogue
et c'est là que là ça c'est difficile
pour la jeunesse parce qu'ils se sentent
pas écoutés c'est ça que nous on voit au
quotidien c'est ça qui fait éco chez le
chez le jeune juste avant d'entendre
Guillaume dardet peut-être une réaction
mais c'est une Colmas verger moi depuis
des années ça fait 20 ans que je suis en
politique je m'aperçois qu'on fait
énormément de choses des associations
comme celle de Monsieur il y en a pas
mal et même beaucoup on fait beaucoup
d'actions aussi vous savez sur les
quartiers et donc on est un petit peu
aussi désolé de voir que ça ne porte pas
ses fruits donc peut-être que on n'est
pas dans la bonne démarche mais j'aurais
quand même rajouter quelque chose je
crois que il faut pas oublier le les
fondamentaux c'est-à-dire l'éducation
familiale c'est quelque chose qui est
important aujourd'hui on voit des jeunes
de 13 14 15 ans jusqu'à 17 ans qui sont
sur la rue à 3h du matin je suis désolé
de le dire je me demande parfois où sont
les parents il y a un moment donné il
faut peut-être se poser des questions
donc il y a toute une trajectoire à
refaire il y a peut-être eu des loupés
il y en a certainement mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui et demain on pourra le
dire au président de la République je
crois qu'on a pas mal de choses à lui
dire demain
juste sur l'aspect élu locaux mairie
visé vous observez aussi dans les
Yvelines à l'image de ce qui s'est passé
dans le quartier du Val Fourré des des
bâtiments publics des bâtiments
municipaux qui sont souvent pris pour
cible durant dans dans ces derniers
jours
oui tout à fait déjà ce week-end on a
malheureusement constaté des incendies
et un incendie sur une école élémentaire
à Versailles sur des locaux associatifs
à Limay et à Poissy on a les locaux de
la police municipale aussi du Guyancourt
qui ont été incendiés donc effectivement
malheureusement ça continue on parlait
aussi la semaine dernière de ces écoles
et on en parlait aussi ce soir de ces
écoles incendies dans la commune de La
Verrière José villecolmaszger vous
faites partie de ces 220 maires qui vont
être reçus demain par le Président de la
République Emmanuel Macron qu'est-ce que
vous attendez de cette rencontre avec le
président de la République pas grand
chose c'est pas bien de dire ça mais je
veux dire déjà on est trop nombreux pour
pouvoir vraiment échanger je crois qu'on
est tous dans la même situation de
colère et de douleur je veux vraiment
dire douleur parce que c'est quelque
chose qu'on ressent moi la colère c'est
pas quelque chose qui m'anime je suis
plutôt dans une démarche de construction
et si on arrive vraiment à évoquer avec
lui certaines choses je crois qu'il va
falloir aussi prendre des décisions
réelles
avec aussi savoir que nous on est là les
élus les associations on est présent et
on doit être ce lien avec le
gouvernement pour faire comprendre ce
qui se passe sur le terrain il s'agit
pas toujours d'injecter de l'argent
c'est pas ça le but l'argent c'est une
chose mais il faut aussi comprendre le
terrain et le terrain qui est porteur du
terrain mais ce qui sent nous les élus
on a été pendant des nuits sur le
terrain avec les forces de police et les
pompiers parce qu'il fallait qu'on les
accompagne et qu'on les aide justement
pour essayer d'être sur le territoire et
c'est là qu'on s'est rendu compte qu'il
y avait des jeunes qu'on connaissait et
qu'on accompagnait des gens déjà dans
des activités c'est là qu'on comprend
pas très bien ce qui se passe donc ce
mal-être là il faut qu'on le fasse
comprendre au président et surtout qui
nous fasse confiance on les connaît bien
on est là on est présent avec les jeunes
on les côtoie on les on connaît leurs
prénoms on sait qu'ils sont ils
travaillent avec nos médiateurs avec nos
éducés ils travaillent avec les
enseignants donc c'est ce que je dirais
demain au Président je veux dire au
président
attention d'être trop loin de nous venez
nous voir écoutez nous faites quelque
chose d'ici soit du concret et je crois
qu'on a pris beaucoup de
retardé le président de la République
peut-être aussi une réaction sur ce que
disait Joséphine Coleman berger sur le
rôle des parents aussi qui est très
important bien sûr après voilà on peut
on peut le voir chez nous que parfois on
peut des familles peuvent avoir des
complications justement à l'éducation
qui peut être voilà perçu différemment
et là justement les associations les
collectivités doivent être là pour
prendre le relais je prends l'exemple un
peu de notre ville où les CBS ou les
maisons de quartier ne sont ne sont pas
ouvert le soir alors que c'est là où
les jeunes ont plus besoin d'être
écoutés d'être canalisés d'être encadré
et ça je trouve c'est aussi un défaut
d'organisation c'est un détail parmi
tant d'autres mais moi je trouve ça je
trouve important que que justement qu'on
fasse confiance au collectif
collectivités et les collectivités nous
fassent confiance sur le terrain qu'on
renoue un dialogue et qu'on qu'on
retravaille ensemble
et ça c'est c'est pour moi le mot
d'ordre pour faire un petit état des
lieux dans les Yvelines alors au niveau
national il dit il est dit que la nuit a
été plus calme et est-ce que vous faites
le même constat dans les e-mails est-ce
que vous avez des chiffres à nous relier
sur les émeuts de la nuit dernière
alors oui effectivement l'année dernière
c'était c'était plus calme que que les
nuits précédentes donc c'est tant mieux
on a entre guillemets que quatre ou cinq
véhicules qui ont qui ont brûlé quelques
quelques poubelles également mais rien à
voir avec la nuit d'avant
un plaisir qui est la situation c'est le
même constat c'est plus calme c'est
exactement le même constat mais on la
vigilance est là je l'ai dit aujourd'hui
à la population qui était là devant
l'hôtel de ville je leur ai dit qu'on ne
baissait pas je dirais la surveillance
entre guillemets parce que il s'agit
bien sûr de les rassurer et puis aussi
parce que c'est notre rôle impératif
d'être présent donc tant qu'on n'aura
pas passé une bonne semaine je dirais
avec avec je dirais les relations que
j'ai avec la police et les pompiers de
savoir que les choses se calment
véritablement on va rester très très
vigilant
ensemble malgré la fatigue que l'on peut
avoir les uns et les autres mais je
pense que la fatigue elle est des deux
côtés donc ça va peut-être porter ses
fruits
blanches à mon actif et j'avoue que
voilà c'est quelque chose que l'on
ressent physiquement mais moralement
également donc on est beaucoup plus
sensible et j'essaie de pas tomber
justement à la fois dans la colère comme
je disais tout à l'heure ni dans le
patauce bien la douleur et là moi j'ai
du mal et je porte la douleur de mes
collègues qui ont été beaucoup plus
impactés que la ville de plaisir avec
des écoles avec des polices municipales
avec des mairies brûlées et ça c'est
pour moi sont les enfin voilà c'est les
porteurs de la démocratie et j'ai
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de mal à
accepter ça donc on va tout faire pour
que les choses se calment mais on va se
reposer les bonnes questions
de l'agglomération de 50 ans divine
qu'on a croisé au rassemblement à
Élancourt il estime à 200 millions
d'euros les les dégâts dans
l'agglomération vous avez déjà une idée
sur sur la commune de plaisir
actuellement on s'est rapproché des
entreprises on a on a des PME qui ont
été entièrement brûlés et en plus
c'était dans le quartier du valibout
alors que ces petites entreprises PME
embauchaient ou prenez des stagiaires du
valibout donc ils ont davantage il y a
encore plus cette tristesse là et on les
accompagne pour leur trouver des locaux
pour une période intermédiaire et
réfléchir à l'avenir avec eux donc
aujourd'hui les estimations des dégâts
sur plaisir je ne l'ai pas mais on
chiffre oui c'est des centaines de
certainement mais on va être derrière
j'ai vu que la région voulait
accompagner on verra ce que fait l'état
des départements bien évidemment va
accompagner en étant vice-présidente
j'ai déjà entendu le président le dire
donc on sera aux côtés avec nos moyens
et moi en tant que mère j'accompagnerai
les entreprises les commerces et tous
ceux qui ont souffert pendant cette
période vous l'observez aussi à
Mantes-la-Jolie sur ces dernières nuits
là on sent un retour au calme mais après
on reste on reste vilain on reste
vigilant sincèrement on essaie aussi de
pas se être débordé par nos émotions
donc on continue sur notre ligne de mire
sur notre ligne directrice c'est-à-dire
de continuer à faire des efforts sur le
terrain de continuer à recevoir les
jeunes malgré la par exemple l'annexe de
de la main de quartier qui a été brûlée
voilà elle a été elle a été vite
déportée sur une autre structure et les
actions et continuent l'accompagnement
ils continuent on baisse pas les bras
mais voilà on essaie de vraiment avec
toute la force de qu'on a dans dans
notre ville de d'essayer de continuer à
pérenniser nos actions ça va être ça
Guillaume dardet vous attendez à quoi
dans dans les prochaines nuits est-ce
que selon vous la calmie va se
poursuivre ou les violences pourraient
repartir est-ce que vous avez vous avez
déjà pas des estimations mais des
projections peut-être pour les nuit
prochaine
non mais c'est très difficile de se
projeter alors on reste on reste
vigilant effectivement on reste prudent
voilà on attend de que ça passe vraiment
sur plusieurs jours et on s'attend aussi
malheureusement au 14 juillet comme tous
les ans il y a toujours un petit peu de
violence urbaine voilà on Tendo jusqu'au
au moins jusque là vous voyez réagir sur
le 14 juillet c'est toujours une nuit
assez sensible oui on a toujours été
très très vigilant on va renforcer
évidemment les contrôles nous on le fait
dans le parc du château donc les entrées
seront vraiment surveillées on aura on
aura soin si tu ne faites populaires et
familiale donc on a cette responsabilité
d'avoir vraiment une surveillance accrue
ce soir-là et permettez-moi malgré tout
je dirais avant de conclure parce que je
ne relais pas les oublier mais de
remercier tous ceux qui ont participé et
qui participent encore la police
nationale les polices municipales et
puis les pompiers bien sûr et puis aussi
toutes les associations qui travaillent
avec nous c'est important de les
remercier parce que tout le monde tout
le monde a vraiment œuvré pour ça non
justement comment mettre fond violence
vous avez esquissé quelques quelques
pistes déjà j'aimerais aussi vous
entendre Guillaume dordet comment selon
vous on peut aller vers une situation de
de fin des violences alors sur le
territoire français mais là en
l'occurrence on parle du département des
Yvelines
c'est difficile à dire mais c'est vrai
que ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure sur
votre plateau c'est vraiment la vérité
c'est je pense que un accompagnement
envers les familles qui ont du mal à
éduquer leurs enfants et leur expliquer
que un enfant de 14 ans parce que ça
reste des enfants n'a rien à faire
dehors avant 22h en pleine semaine voilà
déjà ça peut passer par là et s'il y a
des problèmes de d'éducation il faut il
faut les accompagner il faut les aider
sentiment actuel là qui prédominent chez
les policiers des Yvelines est-ce qu'il
y a un sentiment d'épuisement là on est
quasiment à une semaine d'émeutes
désormais en France
oui effectivement ça commence à comme
comme disait madame la meilleure tout à
l'heure on commence nous aussi à être
fatigué enfin les collègues commencent à
être fatigués à enchaîner des heures
supplémentaires et et oui bien sûr ça
devient ça devient compliqué
de polémiques qui ont agité les
dernières heures il y a eu un communiqué
d'alliance justement votre syndicat
aussi d'une ça police qui appelle je
cite au combat contre les nuisibles et
les hordes de sauvages je cite également
demain nous serons en résistance et le
gouvernement devra en prendre conscience
et puis alors ça n'a rien à voir avec
alliance mais il y a une cagnotte aussi
qui a été lancée par le polémiste Jean
Messia en faveur de la famille du
policier qui a été l'auteur du tir
mortel elle a recueilli plus d'un
million d'euros si vous ne pensez pas
que ça risque de jeter de l'huile sur le
feu et pas d'aller vers l'apaisement
écoutez les termes qui ont été utilisés
sur les communes sur les communautés de
presse nous les assumons parce
qu'effectivement quand vous êtes sur la
loi publique et que vous avez des scènes
de guérilla urbaine ben voilà on n'a pas
d'autres mots donc effectivement ben on
est obligé de d'utiliser des mots forts
pour pour qu'on puisse en parler et pour
que les autorités puissent agir
il y a des élus politiques qui ont parlé
de risques de sédition justement face à
ces propos qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à ça
écoutez après je vais pas polémiquer
là-dessus mais c'est vrai que on est en
difficulté sur sur le terrain enfin mes
collègues en tout cas et alors je
comprends que les termes puissent
puissent éventuellement choquer mais je
pense que les gens qui sont choqués
c'est ceux qui ne voient pas la réalité
en face et
qui pense qu'on est encore
dans un pays de
comme on dit souvent dans la dans la
police un pays des bisounours
ils ont choqué vous en plateau ce sont
des propriétés
qui me choquent parce que on est aussi
alors évidemment on n'est pas au front
comme et la police mais comme je disais
les élus ont été sur le terrain la nuit
justement pour accompagner aussi tout ça
donc on a vu des choses clairement on
les ressent pas dans notre cher
peut-être comme les policiers mais en
tout cas il y a des mots qui moi me
gênent il y en a deux dans le communiqué
particulièrement qui me perturbe parce
que je crois que oui on est sur le
terrain on connaît et on sait qu'ils
sont ces jeunes pas tous mais en tout
cas on sait et pour moi les choses
excessives
me perturbent vraiment je crois que
c'est pas par ce biais là qu'on va
arriver à créer un lien aussi avec eux
donc oui j'entends la colère j'entends
l'inquiétude la fatigue tout ça mais
sont des propos trop forts pour moi en
ce qui me concerne
d'accord avec vous pour moi des
infantilisent un peu ces jeunes là parce
que si on compare un peu aux gilets
jaunes ou quoi que ce soit les réactions
sont différentes les mots sont
différents on peut parler de révolution
mais dès que c'est la ça touche à la
jeunesse on parle d'émeutes et là les
mots ils sont lourds et on a plus
l'impression qu'on a qui a des enfants
en face et il est là le si le problème
et eux ils se sentent du coup exclus
après et on arrive à un cercle sans fin
c'est ça de la haine qui est qui perdure
et qui perdure entre justement le le
corps de voilà la police et cette
jeunesse là et moi ça ça me fait mal
d'entendre des mots comme ça ça me fait
sincèrement mal parce que connaissant la
jeunesse la réaction elle est elle est
spontanée elle est médias elle est
émotionnelle et
c'est c'est pas la solution c'est
absolument pas la solution pour terminer
sur cette thématique justement quel est
le message aujourd'hui que vous voulez
faire passer aux jeunes peut-être
qu'elle aussi qu'est-ce que vous avez pu
enfin quel sentiment prédomine chez eux
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous avez pu
dire échanger avec eux c'est un
sentiment d'injustice la situation du
gène Naël c'est ça a fait cocher chacun
d'entre eux c'est réellement parce que
voilà ils ont déjà tous pour la plupart
vécu des situations compliquées mais je
suis pas du genre à dire c'est soit noir
soit blanc parce que moi personnellement
j'ai eu à faire à des policiers qui ont
été extrêmement bien verts donc c'est
tout ça pour vous dire que c'est pas
soit noir semble soit blanc donc c'est
c'est assez nuancé mais ces personnes là
qui vont manquer de bienveillance et qui
vont faire preuve de d'agressivité et
voilà qui vont être à la à la source de
sécurité de ces agissements c'est
aujourd'hui eux qui doivent être puni
donc ce policier là il doit répondre de
ses actes là parce que la mort de ce
jeune là n'est pas la première et n'est
peut-être pas la dernière en tout cas on
espère
on va continuer le travail j'imagine
avec la jeunesse des quartiers oui on
est en plein dedans depuis de nombreuses
années entre la cité éducative la
réussite éducatives il y a énormément
d'action on a plus de 80 actions toute
l'année avec les jeunes sans parler tout
ce que l'on fait au niveau du sport et
de la culture donc on va continuer on
n'est pas du genre à abandonner bien
évidemment et on est partenaire de
nombreuses associations donc on va
continuer je pense que c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut qu'il faut il faut
persévérer et je n'aime pas entendre sa
puissance fond parce que ça voudrait
dire que faut pas le faire au contraire
il faut continuer mais il est clair
qu'aujourd'hui le dialogue est un peu
distante du donc c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué il va falloir qu'on revienne
encore une fois et encore plus dans les
quartiers il y a pas que les quartiers
d'ailleurs dans ces quartiers là auprès
des jeunes pour leur faire comprendre
que on les écoute on les entend surtout
parce écouter c'est bien mais il faut
les entendre et puis faire davantage de
réunions peut-être aussi avec la police
en tant que police de proximité quelque
chose qui a disparu et que je trouve
dommage parce que aujourd'hui quand il y
a des actions possibles de rencontre
entre les jeunes et la police ils se
comprennent davantage il y a des choses
à faire aussi là-dessus pour comprendre
que il y a pas de monde on vit dans la
même société aujourd'hui c'est notre
rôle à nous adulte de les rassurer aussi
mais il y a des choses qui sont quand
même inadmissibles je ne porterai pas de
jugement sur le décès des uns et des
autres malheureusement il y en a des
deux côtés et je laisse faire la justice
parce que là je ne me prononcerai pas
mais en tout cas on a encore beaucoup de
choses à faire et nous les élus on est
prêt à le faire davantage de proximité
guillaume dordet est une réaction à ce
qui a été dit aussi en plateau mais
davantage de proximité ça peut être une
solution aussi
oui ça peut être une solution aussi mais
pour cela il faut il faut des moyens il
faut des effectifs et surtout nous dans
le 78 on a on a très peu de sorties
d'école et maintenant de nouveaux
policiers qui arrivent donc pour le
mettre en place il faut du monde
bah les élus vont être reçues par le
Président de la République est-ce que
vous souhaitez vous être reçus aussi
dans par le Président de la République
peut-être aussi pour lui faire remonter
les problématiques de terrain
alors moi même non mais effectivement
mes responsables on souvent contact avec
avec le ministre avec le président et je
sais qu'il passe les bons messages et
effectivement ce sera ce sera évoqué ça
c'est certain les mots avec vous
Rudy vous comptez travailler aussi sur
cette thématique au sein de
l'association là sur la thématique
actuelle des violences est-ce que vous
comptez travailler là-dessus avec avec
les jeunes de l'association dans les
prochains mois déjà sur une pièce de
théâtre autour justement des violences
urbaines des violences policières là où
justement on a appelé justement la
responsabilisation à la
responsabilisation de chacun des parties
entre guillemets donc la police de
l'état des gènes des parents nous on
continue notre travail au quotidien mais
il est aussi l'idée c'est aussi de les
sortir aussi de ce tourment de cette
problématique parce que la vie c'est pas
justement que que ça c'est pas que
justement l'affrontement il y a aussi
plein de belles choses et une fois sorti
de de cette actualité de ce de cet
épisode il sera temps justement de
partir sur des choses nouvelles et des
vraiment des belles choses c'est là que
que les solutions vont aussi se
multiplier c'est là aussi que le
développement des jeunes vont va se
faire et donc nous on mis sur ça sur des
actions quotidien on va sensibiliser
aussi mais on va pas s'arrêter que là on
va aussi ouvrir sur voilà sur culturel
sur des vraiment des belles choses c'est
c'est ça ce dont les la jeunesse a
besoin merci à tous les trois d'être
venu en parler en plateau je le rappelle
Rudy enzinga président de l'association
Jeunesse sans frontières à
Mantes-la-Jolie Joséphine coltberger
maire de la commune de plaisir je
précise et je reprécise à nouveau vous
allez être reçu demain par le Président
de la République vous faites partie de
ces 220 maires de France qui vont être
reçues par Emmanuel Macron à l'Élysée
merci également à Guillaume dordes
secrétaire régional du syndicat Alliance
police nationale 78 qui était avec nous
vous le voyez par visio conférence